EU politicians debating brexit this
morning in Strasbourg Apollodorus
Johnson's meeting with the EU Commission
President jean-claude Juncker in
Luxembourg on Monday and let's reflect
on some what's happening at the moment
from Strasbourg joining his mobile
innocent party leader Nigel Farage Nigel
farmer good morning to you what did you
make of the the analogy that was made in
the chamber this morning comparing the
prorogation of Westminster the
Parliament of Westminster with what
happens behind the Iron Curtain in the
old Soviet state well utterly ludicrous
and particularly because it was made by
mr. Vieau Hoff's tat who this very week
addressed the Liberal Democrat
Conference in Bournemouth and said that
the European Union would become an
empire I thought it was a bit rich
coming from him what did you make of
what happened in Luxembourg earlier this
week and the the Luxembourg leader empty
lek turning our Prime Minister we were
just talking to a sketch writer who said
there was a fantastic opportunity for
the Prime Minister actually to to talk
above the hecklers take the hecklers on
he suggested it's the sort of thing you
would have done that other leaders might
have done as well was he Fred well I
think he didn't want the embarrassed it
wasn't in the United Kingdom he was
supposed to be a guest I would have
thought Boris would have been very angry
at the Luxembourg Prime Minister I mean
why would you set a podium up within
yards of a big noisy protest
particularly when Stephen Barclay had
done a press conference that day from
inside the building so Boris made his
choice I might have done it differently
but Boris made his choice
the real point here is not what the
Boris attended or not it is the way in
which the Luxembourg Prime Minister
mocked openly mocked visibly mocked the
podium next to him and and in doing so
mocked our country I thought the whole
thing was disgusting
you talk about Boris his choices he may
face a choice depending on how the
Supreme Court rules this week or early
next week to prolong Parliament again a
second time how would you feel about
that
I don't that you'll do that and you know
I think really the word prorogation has
been misused you know what he's done
here is to call the Queen's Speech a
very normal thing this has been one of
the longest-running parliaments for
hundreds of years the idea that he would
parade Parliament over the end of the
31st of October I don't think he'll do
that and I don't think his own party
would allow him to do that I think what
is more significant is what is going on
with the negotiations around the
backstop you know today we've been
hearing here in Strasbourg from mrs.
Juncker and Barnea
they have no emotional attachment as
such to the backstop they're happy to
look at alternative arrangements it's a
very very different kind of language to
what we were saying before the summer
recess and I think we're potentially
very close to a deal being done on the
17th of October between Boris Johnson
and Monsieur Barnea are you crossing
your fingers and hoping it does but
partly for party political advantage
that it really keeps your party in
business at that stage
well forget forget party advantage I'd
rather not have to be here at all I'm
doing this because I want brexit
delivered and here's my problem
even without the backstop this new
European treaty because that's what it
is is the worst deal in history and it
leaves us completely open and at the
mercy of the EU institutions in terms of
any future arrangement and I think
Michel Barnea let the cat out of the bag
this morning when he said that he hoped
once this was passed that any future
arrangement would be based on the
customs union everything in the treaty
everything in the political declaration
is designed to keep us inside that
customs union and if that's what we
finish up then brexit will not have been
worth it it's five years today since the
Scottish independence referendum I was
just talking to a couple of the
politicians are involved in east and we
ran out of time before I could ask them
a question I wanted to put to them which
is this idea of how you get over the
rancor and there's a sense in which the
Scottish India ref was a forerunner in
terms of the deepness of the depth of
divisions that were created in families
and communities and the rivalries
how do we get over the brexit rancor
that's been created in our nation by
dismissing the fear element you know if
you really look what percentage of the
United Kingdom actually won European
anthems European flags mr. Boerhaave
stats Empire you know it's lower than
15% a lot of other people who've gone
along with the remains I'd have done so
because of the constant economic fear
that has been pumped out by career
politicians backed up by some of the job
multinationals who of course love the
single market and I I think the way we
get over it is to get brexit done and I
think you know 12 18 months down the
road when we're doing much better
comparatively than the rest of Europe
will unify okay Nadja far as good talk
to you thanks very much indeed